the first thing you should know about
michigan governor gretch whitmer there
are a lot of things you should know but
the very first is she takes the
coronavirus
very seriously that's why she banned
people in michigan from buying
paint last year that's why she's now
forcing all two-year-olds in the state
to wear masks it's also why she went on
television recently to warn the people
of michigan
that they should not travel to florida
because florida is dangerous
well at the end of the day this is going
to come down to whether or not everyone
does their part
that's the most important thing this
variant the b117 variant is what is
growing so quickly here in michigan with
the second most of it then
i think right after florida at least
that was the last data that i saw
michigan and florida are not next to
each other but this is the time of the
year that snowbirds come home from
florida
where people are going on spring break
and all of these things
can contribute to spread it's dangerous
to go to florida everyone
has to do their part don't go to florida
well not long
after that we learned that gretchen
whitmer had gone to florida
earlier this year now we don't know how
long she was
in florida we don't know where in
florida she went no one can find out
because her office is citing quote
security concerns
charlie duff worked at the new york
times for a long time he won a pulitzer
prize there then he
left went back to michigan and started
doing even better journalism he's now
the last real journalist in the state
pretty much i would say charlie duff
thanks so much for coming on tonight
so it's a pretty simple question why
don't you as a michigander have a right
to know
what exactly your governor was doing in
florida beats me
i'll tell you what here's some breaking
news i was talking to the florida state
police
and they don't have a record of her
calling up and asking
for some executive security which is
normally the course of action
so she didn't want anybody to know so
madam governor
tell us all when you went
how long you went and when exactly you
returned
that would be nice well you paid for it
and whose jet did you take
well that oh that's the other question
how'd she get there i mean
you could you could be in a position
where your governor is a super spreader
and you wouldn't know so you've
obviously asked these questions i hope
others have asked tell us what kind of
answer you've received from the
governor's office well here's the thing
i find out not only did i find out that
she went i found out that
her health director went down to
margaritaville in the middle of the
pandemic
not fully vaccinated nor was the
governor
i asked the questions i do the
gentlemanly journalistic thing
and i wait and while i'm waiting they
leak it to a friendly outlet
that puts icing on the cake and a couple
of rosettes you know the candy cane so
it all comes out
sweet i want the answers she said her
people said
you can't get that answer because of
ongoing threats
well if there was ongoing threats why
didn't you call the state troopers in
florida
answer it that's a great question and by
the way
this is a trip that's already happened
so how would it be a threat to the
governor's security to tell us something
that she's already done
hello man this is the state i'm living
in tucker and again look
okay you say your dad's sick that's fine
but a servant leader eats last
leaves the burning building last and
leads by example
you don't go see your dad just like i
couldn't see
my dying brother three weeks ago draw
his last breath
because that's what we do i thought
that's what we do
but some of us do and some of us don't
well that's an awful story well it's a
true story
i'm so first of all i'm sorry i didn't
know that and second the state of
michigan
its regulations prevented you from
seeing your brother as he died
but your governor jets down to florida
probably on a private plane
because she wants to see her dad yeah
and you know when she says
we she said a couple weeks earlier
about 10 days before she got caught out
that she hasn't left in 14 months
her last trip was to israel that should
have been
a red flag because everybody knows she
went to the inauguration
you went to see your dad we had we were
locked down by her
last april we couldn't go to our you
know our fishing shack you couldn't
go between this is what we're living
with just
be honest be straight and when people
aren't told
it's straight and clear they start to
rebel so here's what you got
it's over nobody's listening
this thing's gonna spread it's not
killing children
it's still attacking the old and the
obese and
she's lost control of the state that's
the fact exactly
because she doesn't deserve control of
the state charlie thank you for asking
those questions and for your persistence
oh yeah by the way bro i'm going to get
an answer on my lawsuit about those
nursing homes soon and when i do i'll
call you i hope you'll come back
the great charlie duff of michigan thank
you